الحديث عن هذا الموضوع معنا الان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اهلا بك لواء فايز الدويري يعني هذا
الحديث المتواتر الاوكراني المتواتره عن
هذا الهجوم المضاد في التقرير التالي
طرحنا كيف واينا
وايضا هناك سؤال ثالث ومتى اذا ما بدانا
بكيف ما هو التصور لكيفيه بدء مثل هذا
الهجوم المضاد
يعني اشار التقرير الا النقطه الوهن
الرئيسيه في الدفاعات الروسيه وهي منطقه
خرسون زفر وجيا لان هذه المنطقه تعتبر هي
انسب المناطق لشرن الهجوم بسبب طبيعه
الارض اولا
وهي اكثر الطرق المؤديه الى الاهداف
الرئيسيه سواء كانت
او شبه جزيره القرم ولانها تسمح للقوات
بان تنفذ مناوره هذه المناوره تخدم معركه
شبه جزيره القرن لهذا السبب كافه المحللين
كافه التقارير اي قارئ للخارطه يجد ان هذا
هو المكان او هذا هو الكرادور المفضل
للهجوم الاوكراني الان تبقى التفاصيل في
الخطه هذه تبقى قيد
التكهنات اين يذهب الهجوم الرئيسي اين
يذهب الهجوم المساند اين ي الهجوم الثانوي
هذه التفصيلات تبقى ضمن الخطه التي تحمل
درجه سري للغايه لكن
بالسياق الاستراتيجيه العامه هذا هو
الكردور المفضل للهجوم هذا من حيث
اين لكن سؤالك انا من حيث كيف هو اتصور
لمثل هذه المعركه
كيف ومتى الان كيف الان انا تحدثت عن
الكرتون بصوره عامه وهو
الذي يجيب على اين كيف هنا ندخل في
تفصيلات الخطه هذه الخطه احنا كمحللين قد
نقرا الخارطه وافترض نفسي انني من يقود
القوات وارسم هذه هذه الخطه قد قد تتطابق
مع القائد الفعلي او قد تتعارض لكن
المعطيات الارضيه وحجم القوه والغطاء
الناري والغطاء الجوي هي الذي يحدد شكل
المناوره فشكل المناوره اقراه سيكون بهجوم
ثلاثي هجوم رئيسي هجوم مساند هجوم ثانوي
الهجوم الرئيسي سيكون من زبروجيا عبر
الجنيبه او نهر الدينافر الى
الهجوم المساند سيقع الى الشمال منه
والهجوم الثانوي سيكون من خرسون او يبدل
مكان الثانوي مع المساند من حيث متى
اللواء فايز الدويري يعني ما هي ساعه
الصفر لبدء هجوم من هذا النوع
اشار التقرير هناك عوامل ضروريه الطقس
والارض هل الارض موحده او غير موحده لكن
هناك لم يتحدث لان الرئيس الاوكراني
استبعد العامل الثالث وهو الاكثر اهميه
جاهزيه القوات من بعدين
عدد الاليات المدرعه الدبابات الثقيله
والمتوسطه والطائرات هل اكتمل هذا العدد
العدد التقريبي لغايه الان بحدود 300
دبابه هذا العدد غير كافي لتنفيذ هجوم
بثلاث اتجاهات وبالتالي قد يكون هناك هذا
العامل هو الذي يحكم المعادله ويحدد ساعه
الصفر لكن لا اعتقد ان تكون قبل الاسبوع
الاول او الثاني من الشهر القادم
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجيه كنت طبعا
من عمان